foreign
[Music]
thank you
and first of all thank you for inviting
me to here this is uh I prepare this
talk sort of like a tutorial so
hopefully everybody can follow and then
I hope that everybody can follow until
the last slide so in case I'm going to
slow please be patient
okay so all right
uh
Russell which is a thought leader in our
community had for many I don't know for
how long but in his mind learning and
complexion Theory learning and
complexity and cryptography are just two
coins two sides of the same coin how so
learning is about the learning patterns
by a certain class of hypothesis
indicates that you fail to learn
patterns you'll end up with something
also welcome
that is still no random to that class of
hypothesis so in essence they look like
they're just the you know the opposite
of two sides and then uh
either way if you manage to learn as
great information field to learn you've
got something pseudo random you can use
them and a very classical example is the
the boosting algorithm which tells you
that if I can learn a function on any
large enough subsets in a mile delay
successful way then I can actually learn
the function over the entire domain
in a strongly successful way right and
if you negate that sentence basically
you get the hardcore Lemma which says if
you have a function which you cannot
learn a very strong way over the entire
domain that means there must exist some
subset that where you cannot even learn
mildly
and
in this talk I want to view this
connection through the lines of a
concept that's very fundamental to
cryptography and the complexity which is
a simulation which we deal with day by
day where simulation basically says I
want to simulate a very complex object
by a long low complexity object
and obviously mathematically that's not
possible right if my complex object is
something that's only computable in like
exponential time you cannot hope to
simulate it efficiently so therefore
you must say that it only follows
certain distinguishers
now Ned to my surprise
uh as a cryptographer is like very
surprising for me to see at the
beginning is that learning is
specifically doing the same thing where
this complex object is the nature
function that you want to learn and you
want to approximate it using a low
complexity object which is the predictor
that you will learn and obviously this
predictor may not be as good as the
nature function which is maybe very very
complex and therefore all what you want
is that you learned well enough that it
can fool all possible Downstream tests
and applications
so from this view we saw that some of
the concepts in the simulation actually
has many different shapes of forms uh
differentiation between what complex
objects you might want to learn and what
is the class of low complexity objects
you're using and what kind of
distinguishers we have these forms of
weak regularity from TTV work we have
graph regularity we have the concept of
leakage stimulation and this directly
corresponds to in the multi-group
fairness notion multi-accuracy
multi-calibration and outcome
indistinguishability
okay so I hope to convey this connection
and this connection has borne some
fruits which give us New Perspective at
least from my perspective it's very
interesting new Notions new algorithms
lower bounds and the theorems
okay so
um we're gonna start
by seeing first of all the most
straightforward connections that already
exist in the literature
and then we see that the fairness
Community from their perspective
actually has came up stronger Notions
that did not exist before and no
stronger Notions give us and the
connection with crypto and complex that
should give us a bunch of things that
benefit to fairness and from the
fairness perspective because
we have new stronger Notions it or
actually can also go back to complexity
and cryptography with new Notions and
New Concepts
okay
so the talk is going to contain three
parts first we're gonna see the
connection and then we're gonna go from
two Randomness to fairness uh we're
gonna see some algorithms and then in
the last part I'll talk a bit about from
fairness back to pseudor randomness
okay so there is as I warn you a lot of
definitions
and I Was preparing this talk I felt
that this is the most number of
equations I've tapped into my slides
so I will go rather fairly slow I feel
the the the work is kind of consists of
lots of a sort of observations and
connections and certain parts may be
familiar to some of the certain parts
may be unfamiliar so the hope of going
slow is that everybody can sort of learn
something that you were unfamiliar with
even though they fundamentally are the
same thing
um and I ask you to ask me questions if
any point you don't understand okay so I
this is also sort of like a surveying
tutorial
okay so let's see the connection
so basic setup is we're learning
classifications where you have a larger
population and these populations are
described by some features and there is
an outcome which describes whether
certain events happen with respect to
this individual you can think about the
outcome as whether this person has
cancer or this person should be admitted
to college or it could be a cat's dog or
Birds
okay so this distribution is described
by D and the individuals are coming from
Universe X and the outcomes are coming
from a domain o there are two important
cases one is the Boolean outcome case
and the other is the multi-class
classification in the Boolean case it's
like you're predicting that whether
someone is should be automated in the
multi-class classification then you can
think about there are different degrees
of like uh in the case that the one
talked about whether someone is at the
low probability of Dropout someone is at
median probability of job although
someone is at high probability of
Dropout that is a case of multi-class
classification
and typically in our talks about in most
talk so I'm seeing about
multi-calibration uh we focus on the
Boolean case but actually the
multi-class case is going to be quite
Central to this talk so I want to build
that in your mind
we have a nature function which
basically describes to me that for every
individual what's the probability that a
certain what's the probability
distribution over the outcome okay so
therefore this is uh P of I is
appropriate distribution which Delta o
describes the probability distribution
over the set o
so this describes the distribution of
outcome conditions on the features of I
and in terms of notation that I'm
actually going to just view a function
interchangeably as a vector so whenever
write p i something we'll write p i it's
the same as evaluating the function p on
the input I okay
all right
so the goal is that given me sufficient
number of ID samples from the
distribution I feed it into some
training algorithm and I get a low
complexity predictor and the predictor
is also for every individual I mapped to
the distribution of outcome I want to
predict the distribution of the outcome
and a couple things that we might care
about in this pipeline which comes up
quite often is that I want to add low
sample complexity as possible I want my
training algorithm to be as efficient as
possible I wanted the Learned predictor
to be as small as possible and as simple
as possible
now
But ultimately what do I want for the
predictor from the perspective of
applications I want a predictor to be
just as good as a nature function right
but this is quite hard to formalize what
does as good as mean
there are many Notions of good which
we've seen where good could mean being
accurate by the mean
or it could mean calibration and that
means that whenever my predictor
predicts that the distribution should be
V and indeed that the outcome
distribution has the mean b so these two
Notions as written they're really
specialized for Boolean outcomes right
it's not very clear straightforward how
to generalize it to multi-class outcomes
and we can also think about loss
minimization which says that I would
like to minimize the loss with uh the
loss that my prediction would incur with
respect to an outcome relative to a
comparative class of hypothesis I want
my predictor to beat any other
hypothesis inside a class of comparative
hypothesis that is the loss minimization
traditionally all of these Notions of X
good or you can't have many other X good
and you might want to exclude before in
certain class of Downstream applications
that's fine
and but traditionally the the common
theme is that this whatever acts good is
optimized over the entire domain right
now the fairness concern is that as
we're doing this Global optimization it
might be that we achieve very good
Global goodness however we sacrifice
certain subgroups which is small right
and for example this typical book will
be exactly the aggressive types of
cancer which is exactly the subgroup you
want to have most of the good goodness
or it could be minority groups
and therefore the multi-group fairness
on Concepts really brought up to say
that we want to optimize not just over
the entire population but over a
collection of sub-populations
and the fascinating part is that we
might want this collection of
sub-populations to be exponentially
managed our population and also they
might be overlapping if they're disjoint
you can always sort of like train
separate predictors for each of the
subgroup but when they're overlapping
then it becomes much less trivial to how
to do this optimization simultaneously
over order is a population
and once you care about this not just
for fairness concerns and this is
actually also connected very tightly
with robustness multi-objective learning
multi-distribution learning just in the
Learning Community itself
foreign
so how do we formulate this collection
of some populations well we formulated
either collection of functions which is
from the domain to the range of 0 and 1
and there are again two important cases
one is that whoops
one is that these functions are the a
Boolean when they're Boolean they visit
strictly describe a subgroup we can
think about the Boolean function defines
a subgroup
and another case is that the functions
are real they're really values are
between 0 and 1. then this basically
defines a measure
and this measure defines a shifted
distribution which is basically reway to
your original distribution over the
population with these weights the
measure and divided by the density of
the measure a question on the other side
oh sorry yes please if you can go back
to the slide
no
they are overlapping here but
of course you could draw the line so
that each of them is
yeah but the number of such subgroups
would be double exponential
right and hence it's not going to be low
complexity if I trade separate
predictors for the double exponential
number of
non-overlapping subsets it would also be
a sample complexity issue you just a
subset you wouldn't see the most of them
in a Sim yeah okay
okay so we're gonna start to think about
groups in a very soft way like I can
think about the Boolean functions as
hard definitions of groups and you can
think about real function that solve the
definition of groups and sometimes I'll
just talk about them interchangeably
now again what does it mean to say that
I want the predictor to be as good as
the nature function now I want it to be
good for all those shifted distributions
okay for all those groups
and this means that whatever previous
notion of goodness you mean now put a
prefix of multi-group notion and it
means whatever definition we were using
before now I will require all those
definitions to be also over every
possible shifted distribution
and that's multi-group notion in general
and there are two particularly important
definition that we've seen one is with
respect to the goodness of accuracy by
the mean and now when I condition over a
subgroup this is the Boolean version
where the outcome is Boolean and also
the groups are defined in the hard way
and now I want conditional every
subgroup is accurate by the mean another
important definition is the calibration
notion I want now that conditional every
subgroup it is calibrated inside and
that means that within the subgroup
whenever the prediction is V the outcome
it truly have mean V
okay
and I'm going to call this
set
which is a slice that is basically
within the set the collection of
individuals that are classified to have
distribution B
foreign clay I like to visualize things
multi-accuracy says that I would like to
have accuracy which is mean correctness
over the entire set where
multi-calibration says that I want to
have mean accuracy inside each of the
slides okay so here I also draw vertical
bars which is another sort of convenient
concept were used which is the level set
V and these are the individuals which
are predicted to have a specific
distribution B
all right
now an issue which I see a lot of talk
directly use this version I think this
is the most natural uh definition when
we think about the groups however
whenever you want to realize this notion
there's an issue that uh it's gonna be
very expensive we want to deal with
every tiny subgroup and every tiny slice
because just as guy has said there's a
sample complex to issue it might be that
you draw an M samples and you never see
in fact an element that is an individual
that is inside a particular slice if
it's tiny so the more realistic
definition is to only consider large
enough subgroup and a large enough slice
and you can Define the by quantifying to
say I only consider those subgroups
which are Epsilon dance or I only and I
only consider those slices which is like
one minus Epsilon fraction
but this notion is a little bit
cumbersome so in the literature that we
have moved there's a more relaxed
automatic notion which is the weighted
version of those definitions where how
with it basically we're gonna look at
the mean error the difference in the
mean
now waited automatically by the weight
of a slice and this translates to the
multiplicative definition
now multi-accuracy cares about the error
over the entire set and this is
basically the error weighted by the
weight of the set and you can rewrite it
as summing up all the errors inside each
of the slides
with cancellation
okay so if there are difference like
directions of errors in different slices
these arrows are going to these
directions May cancel out
so multi-accuracy is going to look at
you know we want the the mean Arrow
weighted by the weight of a slice and if
you just like
required the error inside each of the
sides to be smaller than Epsilon this is
actually a very weak definition because
the weight of the size will be very tiny
already so instead that we're gonna ask
that the sum of all the errors without
cancellation to be smaller than Epsilon
okay so this is the kind of more sort of
uh weighted version and you can show
that it's actually equivalent to the
previous conditional version once you
have uh considered only large enough
subgroup and slides
okay so once we move to this definition
observe first that this really naturally
supports functions which have real
values which were not the case with this
with the previous definition
so this would support distribution
shifts however still kind of most
naturally handle Boolean outcomes only
and if you want to handle the multi
outcome multi-class case we're always
not just uh zero one value you have to
like reduce it to many many Boolean
cases
all right so now that we have the
definition of multi accuracy is
everybody or the complexity
and crypto people happy
okay
maybe trivia I'm just talking about
yourself okay now here come more trivial
things uh the first connection we saw
literally is Trivial once you look into
the definition of the week regulation
llama you see it's the same as
multi-accuracy let's see
and we could have a like regulation
llama is like uh a very interesting
Concept in complexity and in fact it has
many calories including weak graph
regularity dance model theorem and the
hardcore theorem
I call them I don't know why Russell
didn't call it a theorem
Islamic ruler
I wanted to eat
I wanted to use it for something else
something like incidental that I
and then it didn't work for the thing I
was trying to use it for
okay what's this
okay so let's see now for the learning
theorist what is weak regulation what
coagulation is trying to say that give
me a very dense set defined by P star
that is very complex I want to see
similarly to the by another distribution
that has low complexity
and the following a class of anniversary
okay so what is this very dense set as
we see we say we Define a setting the
soft way which is a buyer function from
the domain to a zero one value so this
is a software definition of of a set and
this function may be very complex right
and we want to simulate it by another
function
and this has low complexity has fairly
small number of level sets and the level
sets are somewhat regular of course it's
not gonna really look like that but
then before a class of distinguisher in
uh with the arrow Epsilon and what does
a fooling mean in the weak regulator I'm
a fooling says that all the
distinguishers
don't have much correlation with the
difference between the true function and
the simulating function
so basically that the the distinguishers
have no power in telling apart the
difference they might be very different
but the distinguishers cannot tell
all right so the full formulating
definition again is that give me an
arbitrary function
um from x201 I have an approximating
function such the approximity function
is indistinguishable to the true one
with respect to C defined in the
correlation sense
and the P tilde has low complexity
relative to the class of distinguisher
and low complexity means that the
maximum the size of pizza is definitely
upper bounded by sort of in some sense
the size of the distinguishers
uh with a factor of polynomial in
epsilon
this is basically the same as
multi-accuracy identical definition
oh with a slight difference is that you
swap to the p p star with the actual
outcome in the definition of we
calculate multi accuracy
all right
um
um it is a it is the same it will have
this form of complexity
how well the approximation quality you
want that is optional and how complex
the class of distinguisher you want to
fold
it has Independence of the complexity of
the nature
I know my definition yeah but doesn't
that make sense
right so C is this might be a majority
of decision trees
okay so the view already pops out which
is that the subgroups in the various
Community equals to distinguishers in
the complexity and crypto community
now let's see more connections so weak
regularity llama is a case that is
building for the Boolean outcomes
actually in crypto that we have a
generalization to handle number the
outcomes this is a concept called
leakage simulation it turns out that
this is exactly identical to the outcome
in distinguishability notion in
particular to the weakest version of no
accessory so let's see that
and once we see that we also see that
the stronger Notions of oh I in fact
equals to Stronger Notions of leakage
simulation which did not exist in crypto
before
so let's see weak regularity really is a
notion for Boolean outcomes because you
consider functions with the range
between 0 1 which is a probability
distribution of Boolean outcomes right
and in fact this distinguisher on the
distinguishing Advantage could be
equivalently written as using the
distinguisher to tell the difference to
try to correlate with the difference
between the outcomes
and so when we want to move to
non-bullying outcomes we're thinking
about the functions that produces
distribution over multiple classes
and in this case we sort of need a new
definition of indistinguishability
because you cannot just take an outcome
and multiply with it right and in crypto
this is uh basically coming from
computational indistinguishability which
is our bread and butter that for any
attacker we consider a class of
distinguisher that has Boolean outcome
that is going to take this non-bullying
uh outcome and the
uh individual I
and map it to a Boolean value and you
want to say that the probability that
this attacker outputs one when it gets a
real account versus the probability this
attacker outputs one when it gets this
modeled outcome which are produced by
the low complexity predictor is very
very small
Okay so
yeah so the concept in JV is that they
will ask
as the
SSA and encryption
and oh
is a correlated random variable with i
as sort of leakage on your encryption
and so what they want to say that here
is the real leakage
and you want to simulate the real
leakage by a low complexity function
that depends only on I
so I can write it in the sense that this
is a this is a ciphertext this is some
leakage
so say that I want to I want to say that
this ciphertext is still hiding my
message right but at the presence of the
leakage I cannot claim so however if I
can simulate this video and this leakage
may be very arbitrary function however
if I can signal this leakage using low
complexity function dependent on the
ciphertext
now
as long as my server text originally is
indistinguishable even against so the
the running time of the simulator I can
again claim that my server text hides
the message
why they want to do it says welcome back
because maybe let's say that leakage
function of the simple key is arbitrary
and it has a routine time two to the end
I do to the Lambda so therefore in the
presence of this leakage actually the
cyber attacks I don't know how to argue
the sub attacks is still hiding but when
I simulate if I can simulate the actual
leakage by low complexity leakage where
the similar to runs only in pre-normal
time in the Lambda
now it actually shows me that the server
attacks at the presence of the
simulation is still hiding
no no but they just won the polynomial
Time by low complexities then being
polynomial time
yeah but the actual lineage of function
may be exponential time oh okay okay no
so just one little time
and the reason they want for a normal
time is because they want to fall for
another time distinguisher foreign
oh it's Finance yeah
okay now here's the definition again and
again that in the liquid simulation you
want the simulator to have low
complexity relative to the class of
attackers and low complexity means uh
you can with a polynomial factor in
absolute and now the size of all
is allowed so this turns out to be
identical to the definition of no excess
oi on in the fairness Community where
they Define a predictor to be
uh with respect to a class of
distinguisher and absolute no excess
outcome indistinguishable if this
definition holds
so now that we see that no access oi is
the same as leakage simulation
it turns out that oh yeah definitely
therefore it also naturally handles
non-bullying outcomes
but the fairness Community has went
further Beyond no access Ori and that's
very interesting for complexity
theorists and cryptographers is that
they consider attackers who might have
some access to the predictor so in
crypto that's the that's a simulation
and there might be different levels of
access that the attacker has
the next level is called sample access
however the attacker actually sees the
predicted outcome distribution
for the specific individual that it gets
or it can consider even further the
attacker just has Black Box access to
this predictor
or it can even have code access where
the attacker just gets a code of the
predictor and these are Concepts that
don't exist in cryptography which I
thought a little bit about but still
don't know yet uh
in in the context of crypto whether
these will be interesting and like what
can it imply
um because it's unnatural for us to
think about the attackers having access
to the simulator I said we don't we
don't think about this case but there
might be very interesting uh
consequences so for Marshall and almost
let's just think about it
crypto
we don't want the attacker to be aware
that there's a simulation going exactly
it only happens in the security proof
yes so it's not clear not clear how to
use it but it's possible when you're
composing the security proof you need to
use the simulator to do something else
that's possible
so I
had a week I have new Notions of say
zero knowledge and whether that can be
useful
okay now that we have to see the
connection we finished the part one I'm
gonna go into part two which is uh from
pseudo Randomness how does some of the
ideas here benefit fairness
you're gonna see new definitions lower
bound and algorithms
the first is the definition that we
propose which very much inspired by oi
I'm not sure uh whether this really
comes from the connection or just comes
from the oi definition
um so this is a statistical variant of
multi-accuracy and a multi-calibration
where I am going to think about this C
which used to be either as uh which used
to describe a group now I'm going to use
it to think about it as providing some
information about an individual
arbitrary in crypto we call this
obviously information right
now uh so this is now mapping now from
the domain to some average reset y
and multi-accuracy means that I want the
modeled outcome and the real outcome to
be statistically close absolute close at
the presence of the auxiliary
information CI about the individual
and the multi-calibration now again just
adds that their statisticals even when
you get the predicted outcome
distribution okay so we think about it
as those two are model outcome and the
real outcome the statistic closed at the
presence of some
limited information about that and
clearly if you see is just a group then
this is basically giving you the group
identity of an individual now can you
differentiate the outcomes
so still naturally handles the
non-bullying version
for the Boolean version It's equivalent
to Prior Notions
and it gives a very simple proof of the
reasons in our view very amazing work of
omniproduction and but because the proof
is really simple I still want to show it
so it also kind of
give you a better sense about the
definition
so what is omnip prediction again here
we want to learn a predictor that
simultaneously does loss minimization
for a lot number of loss functions and
we Define the loss function as taking an
action and an outcome and map it to a
loss
so suppose that I have some outcome
distribution P then I can say that if I
knew what the actual distribution of the
outcome right that is p then I know what
would be the best action to take
in order to minimize the average loss
when the outcome is sampled from the
distribution so basically if I know the
truth about this outcome I should be
able to take the best action and
minimize the loss
so then ultimately I want to minimize
the loss with respect to a predictor
over a distribution D that is
simultaneous for all those different
loss functions
and that's too much to ask for so
therefore we only ask for the predictor
to beat a class of a hypothesis where if
we directly use the hypothesis to
predict what's the best action to take
the loss is going to be much bigger
this is in my opinion such an amazing
object and then such an amazing theorem
that we can have it
really really a big fan and
what's more amazing is that in the uh in
the first initial work where you define
the Omni predictor that you show that we
can achieve it for a class of loss
function which is convex and ellipsis in
the more recent works there is a
remaining theorem which says that you
can actually achieve it for all possible
bounded loss functions the only
constraint on the loss function is that
the loss is bounded between 0 and 1. and
you can actually in fact achieve it if
my predictor is just calibrated and
multi-accurate with respect to the C the
hypothesis what do we see the hypothesis
we're comparing with okay note that this
in fact doesn't require
multi-calibration multi-accuracy is
enough that is really really cool
so using our new definition of
statistical variance it actually use a
very simple proof it contains the three
lines I'm going to show you now let's
just consider the perfect version where
Epsilon 1 and Epsilon 2 equals to zero
recall that our goal is that taken any
bounded loss function and any hypothesis
is C that I want to show that the loss
using the prediction is smaller than the
loss using the hypothesis
in the first step I'm gonna swap the
loss with respect to the real outcome to
the loss with respect to the modeled
outcome
and this inequality follows from the
fact that my predictor is calibrated and
being calibrated means that once you
condition only on the prediction
the model outcome has the same meaning
as the real outcome
hence given the outcome only the
distribution are identical right and I'm
considering the perfect calibration case
the absolute one equals to zero
so this distribution being the same and
of course in fact I should write
equality right because these
distributions are the same
now the next
next is that now once I have switched to
the model the outcome hey P tilde is the
truth I actually do know what's the
distribution of a model outcome that's
exactly picture of the I therefore by
definition the best action function is
taking the best action and that action
is better than any other action right
this is definition
and the last line is that I'm gonna
switch back from the model outcome to
the actual outcome and what does that
follow from that follows you from the
multi-accuracy definition where those
two outcomes are statistically
indistinguishable at the presence of
auxiliary information CI
that's a proof
now with this language it's actually
extremely flexible and I was listening
to Nika's talk and I got so inspired
because I like to see everything from
the lens of a distinguisher and I want
to try if we can do the multi-object
multi-objective learning
that means that I want the loss
to be on smaller even under some
arbitrary distribution shift to GI right
so the zi is the multiplied that's a
distribution shift and everything is the
same as in the previous proof we just
add zi to the two uh
distribution identity and you change the
premise from calibration to Z
multi-calibration and multi-accuracy to
C cross the multi accuracy that's it
okay so now let's see some
other connection
now here is an algorithm from the
community of leakage simulation is that
we can actually learn a simulator with
very tight upper bound and lower Bound
in the size of the predictor
and this upper bound this lower bound
will first of all tell us that there are
actually no dream multi accuracy
multi-calibrational UI predictors that
could be smaller than the distinguishers
we will always end up with a predictor
if you want to follow a class of the
attacker you will end up with a
predictor that is bigger than attacker
yeah that's interesting
lower bound
which is copied from their lower box
[Music]
yeah yes one of the issues with that
right is somehow that you can you would
want right in some way I mean
so you want to see machine learning
result for all distinguishers
Yes except for the star which is a
condition on the lower bound
which is the lower bounding the size of
predictor is that the Predator makes
only black box calls to some attackers
in the class and whenever you call the
predictor to predict it for individual
eye it is also going to call those
attackers on input side however this is
so far the only way that we know we know
how to build the predictors all the
predictors satisfy this constraint
s if you want to bypass the lower bound
and we have to bypass this constraint
okay so this information Theory it's
information theoretic yeah
yeah maybe conversational assumptions
may help with that for those of the
anemone
interesting
if the predictor is only making Black
Box calls so it has to make at least one
poll would have to be at least the size
of one yes sure it says that you have to
make more costs so so kind of the
theorem shuffly was interested in would
be trivial in this model
if you cannot be smaller than just one
Max
that's trivial under this restriction
yeah and the point is that you can even
say one over Epsilon scale yes
right but but you definitely can't if
all you're doing is making left books
calls to these things
yes
yeah yes you're right you're right
um actually we can really copy from the
upper bound algorithm to become a new
algorithm for multi for example access
oi which is not existing in the liquid
simulation
so I'm going way too slow
is it I prefer so many slides type so
many questions I want to make them worse
I would say
remember my collection
okay so the algorithm is using general
no regret learning the generality is
what appeals to me and no reply learning
is basically a game between a meme
player and a max player where the there
is a collection of Peel strategies o and
in each of the random means layer can
play a mixed strategy which is the
distribution overall and the max player
can choose a loss function which Maps
every gives a loss for every pure action
right and once you define the loss
function the mean player suffer a loss
which is the average loss
evaluated on the outcome sampled from
his mixed strategy
now the No Regret strategy which is
played by the mean player is defined by
two things an initial distribution would
be tell that zero should be and then
update to rule which says that once I
receive a loss function which could be
arbitrary how do I update the previous
mixed strategy to be the next mixed
strategy and the max player could play
arbitrary strategy that is a stateful
and adaptive and the magic of the node
required learning is there exists no
regret strategies that give me no regret
guarantee which says that the average
loss of playing the No Regret strategy
were the pure strategy is sampled from
all those different uh mixed strategies
that the meme player choose according to
the No Regret strategy this is going to
be better than the loss for any fixed
mixed strategy cross all the different
iterations right this is no regret
guarantee
and we have examples of projected
gradient descent multiple width in the
case of multiple weights it says that no
required strategy no regret guarantees
start to kick in once your number of
iterations is roughly Epsilon square and
the dependency on the pure strategy
space is a log in the space of the field
strategy
all right so how do I go from leakage
from No Regret learning to leakage
simulation which is identical to no xxy
recall that there what I want is to find
a predictor that have the small
distinguishing Advantage for all
attackers
roughly the algorithm is going to look
rather the same which is you start with
initializing your initial predictor and
then you'll run in many iterations
trying to look for whether there is a
violation with a high which is an
attacker a t that has high
distinguishing advantage against the
current predictor once you find such an
attacker you're gonna update your
predictor to patch it up and you keep
doing this until you cannot you reach a
predictor that doesn't have any attacker
so it's obvious that if the algorithm
ever terminates it will return you
something that is uh no xsy which is
good liquid simulator
so how do I construct this algorithm
using just no regret basically that
we're gonna run no required strategy for
every individual eye so you have an
exponential number of individuals
whatever one of them you're thinking
about there's a separate no regrets
learning that is happening
so initialize your predictor with the
initial strategy of the No Regret
learning
I'm going to predict that
okay so once you have found a violation
attacker we want to define the loss
function for the individual and that
loss function naturally should be the
output of the attacker and in fact all
what it does is take
any outcome and because we're
specializing for particular individual
eyes it's just the output of a or o and
I we're going to see the connection with
the distinguishing advantage in a second
once you have the loss function use the
No Regret update to update the
prediction for that individual done
that's algorithm now let's see that why
does this algorithm actually ever
terminate so suppose that the strategy
satisfy no regret learning then my no
regret algorithm is going to run in the
most t iterations
first we're running no regret for every
individual so no regret to supplies for
every individual means that on if I use
the predictor strategy
the loss I suffer across all the
iterations is smaller than the loss I
suffer with respect to any fixed
distribution
of my oi star and in particular I could
use the real outcome distribution o i
star which is a pi star
now I Define my loss function to be with
respect to my attacker plug in the
definition this gives me this guarantee
as you can see already that the left and
the right subtract looks like the
distinguished advantage of the attacker
the only difference is that here we're
looking at a specific individual eye
instead of looking at a distribution
over I but if you have guarantee for
specific individual I of course there
are holds for any distribution of I so
also take expectation over the
individual distribution now you'll get
that
over or over t iterations
the average distinguishing advantage
must be bounded by Epsilon
so suppose now my algorithm actually
runs more than two iteration it means in
order iterations I am finding a
violation where the distinguishing
advantage of 80 is bigger than Epsilon
and that would imply that my left hand
side will be bigger than Epsilon
and that's a contradiction with the No
Regret guarantee
done
so this is the algorithm immediately
from No Regret guarantee using multiple
weights the algorithm cannot run more
than this number of iterations in each
iteration it is going to take
information theoretically at most this
number of
samples and hence the overall sample
complexity is
this
so
how can I go from the outcome and
distributability to say
uh
sample xsoi which didn't exist before
for liquid simulation now basically I
want my attacker to also take in the
prediction for the
outputs
turns out that the algorithm is
basically the same identical as before
the only difference is that when I
Define the loss function I'm going to
Define it to give the attacker the
current outcome prediction
that's the only difference and that is
allowed because in the Minimax strategy
the maximize the maximizer is allowed to
choose the loss function in arbitrary
adaptive and stateful way in fact it can
depend on all the previously so far
defined predictions in fact they could
even depend on like the overall
prediction not just for an individual
eye when defining the loss for a
particular individual
and the sample complex is this the same
now if I want to use this algorithm to
learn something else
for example the statistical version of
our MC all what I need to do is to
formulate the right class of attackers
and plug in the numbers right
and this statistical notion basically is
equivalent to checking the probability
of every possible event is very close
so therefore I can define a class of
attacker which is
parameterized with a specific function
specifies which auxiliary information
I'm going to look at and specify which
event I am going to look at and its
output is to check whether a certain
event happened
now this says that if I if for every
such attacker the distinguished
Advantage is very small it basically
says that for every C this event
difference probability of the event
difference is very small and hence tells
me that there are statisticals
if I want to work with the original
version the conditional version of
multi-calibration note that this is
definition which is you sum up the error
inside all the slices without
cancellation it's a little bit
problematic to deal with this absolute
sign in fact
and has the previous algorithms often
what they do is that they look at they
look for violation in its individual
slides but you can deal with the
absolute sign by looking at this class
of attacker which takes all multiplied
with CI
and then it kind of like
puts the arbitrary sign for each of the
slides
so if we have small distinguishing
Advantage for every possible C and
arbitrary assignment of science you
automatically have an upper bound over
the sum of absolute value
so now we can plug in those numbers and
give me this
specific numbers I'm really
running out of time uh
in particular we want to highlight that
because our generalization to the
non-bullying case we significantly
improve the sample complexity when we
work with multi-class classification
okay so
the last part which I don't really have
time to go through which is to go
through the
fairness Notions because we saw that
a complexity looks at basically the
lowest level of fairness and once the
fairness Community defines the more
complex Notions of families they can
give us new Concepts in complexity and
crypto
but I run out of time so we leave this
part too
the offline
[Applause]
I have very fancy graphs let me show you
at least
[Laughter]
after a question or two
statements of what kind of yeah
oh I'll be delighted to do that
okay so we saw that the multi accuracy
equals to weak regularity and naturally
you would ask whether multi-calibration
gives you stronger versions of
regularity in some sense it does because
we've already saw through the oi
hierarchy that the higher Notions of OI
gives us stronger leakage stimulation
but it turns out that there's more
semantic versions of those regularity
which is in the context of a graph which
is very interesting their graph
regularity so weak regularity implies a
weak notion of graph regularity it turns
out then you can say you can very
intuitively Define the multiple
multi-calibration gives us a new
intermediate level of regularity and
there is a stronger version of
regularity in the graph Theory which is
summarizes regularity which will turns
out to give us back a strict notion of
multi-calibration which is implicitly
used in Prior works when you are
algorithm the algorithmetry achieves the
strict version of the multi-calibration
below this notion was not explicitly
defined
what is it
yeah so what is it so in the version of
the graph which roughly saying you have
very dense and complex graph look this
looks very complex right almost to the
random
and you want to approximate this graph
by a low complexity object in which case
which is a small partition of your
vertices
partition with the vertices I'm sort of
like defining instead of each of the
entry points is now going to be dij what
is like dij it's sort of like the
density within this partition VI times v
j
now this gives me a way to Alternative
way to count how many edges there are
inside a particular cut I basically want
to say that my approximation gives you
roughly the same number of edges
for all possible cuts
now you can Define this approximation in
the multi-accurate way which is that uh
over the entire cut the proximation is
good that's a freeze command
you can Define it in the
multi-calibration way
which it says
I want the arrows to be small without
cancellation I'm going to add up all the
add up all the errors in each of the
slides but I do not allow cancellation
when we go to
the
summarize this regularity
he says that I want to
allow that the violation inside each of
the partition or your level set
to be different
okay
and even when you add up all those
violations are still upper bounded and
that corresponds to strict
multi-calibration which is you're not
looking at a consistent set
you're saying each of the level set I'm
going to find the within each level set
the maximum subgroup that gives me the
biggest error in that slice and even
adding all of this up it is bounded
so that's an ocean
okay
yeah that's it
yeah oh yeah just in case someone was in
fact
I remember
you so I said something about the
complexity of achieving the statistical
notion of money accuracy oh yeah so
I have a motivational way of going back
sorry
[Music]
here here
because because I could not get into it
so it's a little bit tricky because once
you look at this class of attacker
which is this kind of attacker
so the number of such attackers is
basically a number of is the size of C
multiply with number of events okay a
number of events is true to the Y times
o times does the image size of the
predictor
so if your predictor is a continuous
value that I don't really I cannot bound
every possible event so we have to
discretize
the image of the prediction and you can
always discretize that it's rather in
its uh in the like uh Boolean case that
you basically consider intervals of
widths one uh of which Epsilon but once
you go to the multi-class case you have
a high dimensional Cube and then you
orientize it this Cube they're gonna
come up to be many many many grid points
right which where it's the number is
exponential in the width to the
dimension
and that is sort of like leading to a
high complexity sample complexity
um
I guess also you need to be able to from
The Learning Systems
yeah
that is right
although in some of the cases you can
actually
um
someone actually do better because
we decides within the case of
omniproduction and multi-objective
learning
right here for example in this case
where I talked about if you want to kind
of learn Z episode 1 multi-calibration
as I was talking about in the
statistical variant you will have a
sample complexity which will depend on
the
uh image size obviously
right and it's rather inefficient
because if I'm thinking about the Z as a
distribution shift the image size of Z
is like gigantic it's excellent it's a
continuous so far right it's infinite
however if you all what you want is to
full distinguishers that are linear
in this value that you care about
then it's equivalent to just look at
another random variable which is sampled
using the eye
if I had to swap the New Orleans
expectations instead of directly
multiplied with c i I multiply with oiz
it still holds it gives me the
conclusion I want so therefore in the
statistical notion all what I need is to
say that o i z with p i tilde
uh and oi star is statistically close to
oiv with pi tilde with oy tilde
which were significantly reduce your
sample complexity you have to look into
what the distinguishers are doing
that's a good point to end on thank you
very much